Gary Klein back with us covers the Rams
for the LA Times the status of defensive
tackle Aaron Donald the deadline today
looks like the deadline will pass House
morale at Rams camp Gary well Dan this
is nothing new for the Rams with Aaron
Donald dotted trading camps so I would
say morale is high it's a little bit hot
and muggy for the Rams here in Baltimore
not not the weather they're used to in
Southern California down at UC Irvine
but all things considered they seem like
a pretty happy group right now any
chance this goes into the regular season
with an Aaron Donald I suppose there's a
chance but I would be really surprised
if it gets to that point I mean again
Aaron Donald sat out last year and the
Rams didn't blink he came back he's the
NFL defensive player for the year so on
some level I'm sure Sean McVeigh and the
Rams are saying great keep him out of
training camp he doesn't get injured
we'll get serious after the preseason
ends and really they do have about an 11
day window after the final preseason
game in the beginning of the regular
season so I wouldn't be surprised if
things start to heat up at that point
but to this to this point they seem to
be at a standstill if we're picking
sides here which side where are would
you be on with management versus Aaron
Donald here you know I think this is a
situation where they're probably both
going to come out winners I mean at this
point there has to be a deal on the
table that would make him the
highest-paid non quarterback in the
league
obviously he wants a little bit more
than that and from the the Rams
standpoint you know they want to lock
him up for as long as they can they
don't want to have to resort to the
franchise tag and that way of
controlling him so I think you know
right now you got quarterbacks making 20
to 20 you know 20 good quarterbacks like
you're in Rogers and Phillip Rivers
making that I my sense would be on Aaron
Donald's standpoint they're looking at
the salary cap and how that's gonna a
new collective bargaining agreement
coming in a couple years and I'm
guessing that the sticking point is not
the dollars as much as it is those kinds
of factors like what's going to happen
when this contract becomes instantly
absolutely
expectations are pretty high Gary they
too high for the Rams
yeah or for Donald well you know more
for the Rams
I don't think they're too high because
Shaun McVeigh you know has I think
showed last year that he can put an
offense together Jared Goff you know
erased the questions that were there
after his rookie season Todd Gurley you
know has a new extension Brandon cooks
who's there just signed a big extension
as and is regarded as a missing piece so
I think that offense is in place the
defense with the addition of endemic and
Su should be stronger as well as a key
to lead there Marcus Peters so I don't
think that the optimism the Super Bowl
buzz whatever you want to call it is
unfounded but of course they have to go
out and play and get lucky that no one
gets hurt
I don't know if you can have too much
talent but you can't have too much
personality the Rams have a lot of
talent they have too many personalities
you know Dan I think we talked about
this a few months ago when they made
those trades for to leave and Peters and
and signed a sue and now we've at least
had a small sample size we've seen them
in organized team activities mini camps
we're seeing how they're kind of melding
during training camp
it all looks great right now but I think
you raise a good point this is a locker
room that had no problems last year and
if this thing goes sideways with those
personalities in the locker room there
is definitely potential for great drama
and I'm also curious about this that it
felt like the Rams exceeded expectations
last year and by doing so almost you
kind of turned up the clock a little bit
on let's go for it
I don't know if they if they weren't
winning 10 11 games that would they have
gone all-in and getting Adamic ensue and
then keep to leave and Marcus Peters
did we speed up the process a little bit
based off of last season or was this the
original sort of timeframe for them no I
think it definitely speed up speeds up
the process and remember they've got
this new stadium that they're trying to
sell fans and Suites and everything else
for coming up so the most important
factor in
this really dan that's sped up the
process is the development of Jared Goff
because they've got a starting
quarterback a guy who was in the Pro
Bowl last year who's under contract at a
you know ridiculously affordable price
this is their window right now
where they can afford to pay Todd Gurley
and Brandon cooks and Aaron Donald
because Jared Goths coming down the pike
and he's probably going to be a twenty
five to thirty million dollar
quarterback in a few years this is their
time to to go for it so I think that's
one of the main factors they went all-in
have you seen enough of golf that you
know what you saw last year is what
we're going to continue to see no I
think you know I'm still skeptical on
some levels he made a great leap from
his first year to a second year but I
think a lot of that is attributable to
Shawn McVeigh and the offense that was
installed he takes it you know Goff is
in a great position you know in that
system and I think we'll have to see if
he can make that leap in year three the
thing he didn't show last year the Rams
went a lot of games but Goff didn't win
any games he didn't lose any but he
didn't win any and I think for him to
kind of really be considered a guy who's
elevated his game we need to see him win
a game in the fourth quarter or do
something that takes him to the next
level I'm also curious we see this in
baseball we're seeing it in basketball
they call it the process or they call it
tanking with the NFL it feels like these
GM's are looking for their quarterback
that they can keep they had that rookie
salary and you've got somebody like
Russell Wilson in Seattle and then you
build around those quarterbacks while
you can because you can afford to do so
and it feels like you know that's what
the Rams are doing now when did this
process begin do you remember which team
you know I think Russell Wilson as you
pointed out is a great example with you
know they kind of found him right in the
third round or whatever Pete Carroll and
Schneider realized what they had and
then they started loading up that
defense giving those guys you know big
contracts Richard Sherman and everyone
else and they built a winner and I think
the Rams playing in the NFC West learned
from that Seahawks are a little bit of a
model and now I think the Rams are also
taking it another
further at least in this offseason les
needs ability to identify guys like
Marcus Peters and a keep to lead before
you know the free agency period started
or any of that he made those trades
before he could they could really even
be on the books as guys that were
available and I think that's good might
be the next trend but certainly this
quarterback building around the young
quarterback under control with a salary
that's affordable seems to be the way to
go when you see Sean Mannion please tell
him we said Aloha
I definitely will you know he's a new
father just had a baby girl and we'll
see he's probably gonna get a lot of a
lot of opportunity here in the preseason
because I'm guessing McVeigh is gonna
sit McGough and keep him out of harm's
way
we'll see if Sean Mannion can make a
case for getting an extension with the
Rams or putting on a show for some other
teams that might pick them up and I
don't know if this is an accurate quote
or not but you can go with it I think
Sean Mannion said having a baby is the
second greatest thing that's happened to
him aside from being on this program so
you can ask him
I mean investigate Garak your journalist
but you can ask him about that thank you
Gary thanks again that's Gary Klein LA
Times Rams beat writer for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]